الفضيحه دي انقطاع الكهرباء اثناء الكلمه
وزير الماليه بتجمع اقتصاديا في الخرطوم
الى موقف محرج عقب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي اثناء كلمته امام التجمع عن
اقتصاديا عربي بقاعه الصداقه في الخرطوم
حيث تستضيف الخرطوم اعمال اجتماعات مجلس
الوحده العربيه الاقتصاديه
نزلنا الصبائي
بقطع الكهرباء ودخول القاعه في ظلام دامس
اطلق عبارات ناقده همسا امام المايكات في
القول الفضيحه دي والناس فضايح وتسائل كيف
تقولون للناس تعالوا استثمروا عندنا
[موسيقى]
وحاول وزير الماليه تدارك الموقف المحرج
سريعا بدعوته لمجلس الوحده الاقتصاديه بان
تكون الكهرباء احدى القطاعات المستهدفه
باستثماراتهم وقبلت بادرته تلك التصفيق
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وهذا مجال المخصصه للاستثمار العربي
ومرحبا بكم في الاستثمار في الكهرباء
والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتغير
المناخي ما اثر على معدلات النمو
الاقتصادي وارتفاع حجم البطاله الغذائيه
[موسيقى]